mauvaise nouvelle pour le portefeuille
des automobilistes la hausse de 13
centimes sur le lit du sans plomb a bien
été remarqué à la pompe 1 euro 50 6 le
litre contre 1 euros 43 il ya trois
jours une hausse de 5 euros sur un plein
de 40 litres
alors forcément les consommateurs sont
mécontents c'est d'autant plus c'est
déjà difficile
au prix où les tresses un débit de plus
c'est cosy dans le porte monnaie
les déplacements sont limités parce que
quand on fait un plein place à douma pas
de chaîne non pas ma méthode mes
tatouages ou à peu près il faut limiter
les palois démarche inutile un budget
transport qui s'alourdit et des
automobilistes qui limitent leurs
déplacements pour la faute martinique
cette hausse du prix du carburant
pourrait aussi avoir des répercussions
sur l'économie de l'île on va prendre de
l'essence au lieu d'apprendre autre
chose et on va faire des choix
c'est ça et ça va impacter le pouvoir
d'achat ça l'impact et d'économie et
c'est le serpent qui se mord la queue
basse que si le consommateur consomme
pas il n'y a pas de développement
l'économie non plus en mai le sans-plomb
augmente donc de 13 centimes et le
gazole ne prend qu'un centime d'euro le
prix de la bouteille de gaz lui diminué
de 43 centièmes alors pourquoi cette
différence
c'est en fait le code de l'énergie qui
fixe les modalités pour le calcul des
prix en outre-mer plus précisément c'est
la dieccte la sara lui communique le
prix de sortie du carburant en fonction
du cours du baril et des coûts de
fonctionnement qui n'ont pas varié
à cela s'ajoutent les coûts de
distribution et les taxes qui détermine
le prix final de l'essence quand la sert
à fabriquer de l'essence à partir de
brut
nous achetons du produit brut pour le
transformer et nous l'achetons à partir
de produits dont le prix est fixé comme
pour la bourse à la minute près là la
seconde près sur un marché où
s'échangent ses produits donc nous
allons acheter le produit à intriquer
fixés par le marché et ce qui s'est
passé au mois de mai au mois d'avril
pour la fixation des trucs de du mois de
mai c'est que ces cours ont augmenté de
11% dans la zone la forte demande dans
l'hexagone a fait varier les cours du
pétrole sans compter le contexte
géopolitique en libye au venezuela et en
iran avec des exportations en baisse ou
frappés d'interdiction